[Which of the following could be simplified or removed without changing the result]
[function platos_republic(a,b) {]
Let's go through the lines 1 at a time. A times 1.
This is the same as A=A because anything times 1 is just itself.
So this assigns the new value of A
to be equal to the old value of A.
So this is actually equal to just doing nothing.
So I could totally remove this line
without changing the result of Plato's Republic.
B gets B+0. This is the same sort of theory.
This reduces to B gets B
because adding 0 to something doesn't change its value.
So I could just drop this statement entirely.
A=A+B. That looks like something important might be going on.
Let's hold on to that for a bit.
In fact, let's go down here and see.
Eventually we're returning A.
I can't remove this line
because we actually need to return A to have the same value.
And if I'm going to return A, then I need to keep this line--
A gets A+B--so that I know what the right value of A is supposed to be.
But--and this is the potentially tricky bit--
I can remove B=B+2.
Even though there's no arithmetic simplification that I can perform,
I just don't need the line!
B isn't part of the return value.
No one else can ever see it.
We throw it away after this point.
Formally in computer science we call this "dead code".
It has no effect on the rest of the program.
So I could drop these 3 lines,
and all that Plato's Republic is really doing
is summing its 2 variables together, returning the result.
Plato's Republic is a dialogue written in about 380 BCE
that talks about the definition of justice.
The phrase "who watches the watchers"
often comes up in discussions or criticisms of Plato's Republic.